OK, you're a middle school teacher. Here's a situation that apparently happens all the time. A kid walks into your classroom wearing a hat. There's a rule-- hats are not allowed in school. You tell him to take it off. He does.
好的，你是中学老师。这种情况似乎经常发生：一个孩子戴着帽子走进你的教室。学校有规定——校内不允许戴帽子。你告诉他摘下来，他也照做了。
Ten minutes later, you're teaching, you look at the kid, he's wearing the hat again. Again, you tell him to take it off. This time, he doesn't. And then he escalates the situation. He curses to himself. What do you do?
十分钟后，你正在上课，看向那个孩子，他又戴上了帽子。你再次告诉他摘下来。这一次，他没有照做。而且他还让事态升级，对自己骂骂咧咧。你该怎么办？
Right then and there, I'd say, "That response was not acceptable, and I won't tolerate that. Take off your hat, and put it into your bookbag."
就在那一刻，我会说：“那种反应是不可接受的，我不会容忍。摘下帽子，放进书包里。”
Serena Nickle in Connecticut says that usually works. You demand compliance. Though one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, asked over a dozen middle school teachers. Jose Vilson in New York would have a very different response.
康涅狄格州的塞雷娜·尼克尔（Serena Nickle）说，这通常很管用。你要求学生服从。不过我们的制片人之一查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）询问了十几位中学老师。纽约的何塞·威尔逊（Jose Vilson）则会有截然不同的反应。
"Let's have a conversation."
“我们谈谈吧。”
So like, you're in the middle of teaching, and you would say, "John, let's have a conversation about your hat?"
所以，你正在上课，你会说：“约翰，我们来谈谈你帽子的事？”
Yeah. Absolutely.
是的，绝对会。
Jeff Reamer says that the key is no conversation, no stopping instruction at all, as he gives the kid a demerit on the kid's weekly behavior report.
杰夫·里默（Jeff Reamer）认为关键在于不要交谈，不要停下教学进度，直接在他的每周行为报告上记一个过。
If I'm saying, "Ladies and gentlemen, today, we are going to talk about three different styles of argumentation-- John, right now, you're choosing to earn a major deduction, because you put the hat back on. Please take it off. We're choosing to learn about the three different types of argumentative styles-- ethos, logos, and pathos." It'd be like that.
如果我正在说：“各位，今天我们要讨论三种不同的论证风格——约翰，你现在选择要扣分了，因为你又戴上了帽子。请摘掉它。我们继续学习这三种论证风格——即所谓感召（ethos）、逻辑（logos）和情感（pathos）。”就是这样。
Smooth, right? Jamien Jacobs in Maine would not use any words at all. She'd give the kid a look. She'd do the whole thing in a look.
很顺畅，对吧？缅因州的杰米恩·雅各布斯（Jamien Jacobs）根本不会用语言交流。她会给那个孩子一个眼神。她全程只用眼神来处理。
If he doesn't take off the hat, one of my techniques is I take my shoe off, and I chuck it.
如果他不摘帽子，我的绝招之一就是脱下鞋子，然后把它扔出去。
What?
什么？
[LAUGHS].
[笑声]。
You take your-- wait. You take your shoe off?
你脱下你的——等等。你脱掉鞋子？
Yeah. Like if I'm wearing clogs, I'd take off my shoe, and I'd put it in my hand, and I'd say, "OK, take off the hat, or I'm going to chuck it."
是的。比如我穿的是木屐，我会脱掉鞋子拿在手里，然后说：“好了，把帽子摘了，不然我就扔了。”
Like, "I'm going to chuck it at you?"
你是说，“我要把它扔向你？”
Well, they never know. But I've thrown plenty of shoes, and kids love that, too.
嗯，他们永远不知道我会不会扔。但我已经扔过很多次鞋子了，孩子们也很吃这一套。
All across the country, across different schools in different states, when it comes to disciplining young people, teachers are winging it. In 19 states, you're still allowed to hit kids if they think that'll work. And lots do. Chana asked the teachers what they learned about controlling their classrooms in their teacher training programs. Most of them said, not much.
在全国各地、各个州的不同学校里，当谈到如何管教年轻人时，老师们都在临场发挥。在19个州，如果老师认为有效，他们仍然被允许体罚学生。而且很多人真的这么做。查娜问过老师们，他们在师范培训项目中学习过如何管理课堂吗？大多数人说，没学到什么。
There's this great book that's out now by a reporter named Elizabeth Green, about teacher training. It says, "Incredibly, at some education schools, disciplining kids, managing your class, it's not even a subject on the curriculum." When you ask teachers, OK, so really, how did you learn to do that thing that you do with your voice, your face, your shoe, they often answer with a name, a kid's name-- that kid taught me so much.
现在有一本很棒的书，是记者伊丽莎白·格林（Elizabeth Green）写的，关于教师培训。书中写道：“令人难以置信的是，在一些教育学院，管教学生、管理课堂甚至都不是课程内容。”当你问老师们，你们到底是怎么学会用那种声音、那种表情、那只鞋子来管理课堂的，他们通常会给出一个名字，一个学生的名字——是那个孩子教会了我很多。
I had this one student, Alex, who-- I'd tried everything.
我有个学生叫亚历克斯，我——我尝试了一切办法。
His name was Jeff.
他的名字叫杰夫。
I'll call her Z.
我叫她Z。
I'll give her the name J. Yeah, J.
我叫她J。对，J。
We'll call him Johnny. We'll call him Johnny.
我们叫他约翰尼。我们叫他约翰尼。
Johnny and Z and Jeff and Alex are our nation's education school. These are the kids who were so hard to discipline that teachers just had to figure out what to do. So each teacher finds an approach that works for them.
约翰尼、Z、杰夫和亚历克斯就是我们国家的教育学院。这些孩子太难管教，老师们只能自己想办法。所以每个老师都找到了适合自己的方法。
Does it work for the kids? Who knows? There's no clear answer. There's no best practice that educators agree on.
这对孩子们有效吗？谁知道呢？没有明确的答案。教育工作者们并没有统一的“最佳实践”。
Which is weird, since this is where kids should be learning to control themselves and how to live with others in the world. It's so essential. This is so basic. And there are lots of educators out there who are convinced that the way that we do discipline isn't just ineffective. They think it's actively messing kids up.
这很奇怪，因为学校本应该是孩子们学习自我控制和如何与他人共处的地方。这太基础了。但很多教育工作者确信，我们现在的管教方式不仅无效，而且认为这正在给孩子们造成实质性的伤害。
So today, we're going to talk about schools, but not about curriculum or testing or standards or any of the other stuff that people usually talk about on the radio and in the media when they talk about schools. Today, we're going to talk about discipline, because, you know, you kind of have to nail discipline before you can do anything else in a classroom.
所以今天，我们要谈谈学校，但不是谈课程、考试、标准，或者人们在广播和媒体谈论学校时通常提到的那些东西。今天我们要谈论管教，因为你知道，你必须先搞定管教，才能在教室里做其他任何事情。
Chana Joffe-Walt has been looking into this for months. She has learned things are not going so great with discipline. And lots of educators and parents are asking, is this working? Is this the best we can do? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特已经研究这个问题好几个月了。她发现管教方面的现状并不理想。许多教育工作者和家长都在问：这样做有用吗？这是我们能做到的最好方式吗？这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "Time Out."
第一幕，“暂停”。
OK, so let's start this show about discipline in schools at the very beginning of a kid's school experience, in preschool, with kids so young that you would think it would be pretty straightforward how to handle behavioral problems when they act up. Like, how bad can these kids be? And at this young age, this is where the question first emerges of whether the wrong kind of discipline in school will screw up a kid, maybe for years to come. Here's Chana.
好，让我们从一个孩子学校生涯的最初阶段——学前班——开始这期关于管教的节目。对于这么小的孩子，你可能认为处理他们的行为问题应该是相当直接的。毕竟他们能坏到哪儿去？而在如此幼小的年纪，一个问题开始浮现：学校里不当的管教方式是否会毁掉一个孩子，甚至影响未来多年？下面请听查娜的报道。
JJ's conversational style is to tell you things he knows for sure. He's no fan of ambiguity, sticks with the facts. He's five. He does not like salad. His new house is OK, but it does not have a pantry.
JJ的谈话风格是告诉你他确定知道的事情。他不喜欢模棱两可，只坚持事实。他五岁。他不吃沙拉。他的新家还不错，但没有食品储藏室。
He can spell the word "loss." His mom has a belly, because there's a baby in there. The baby will have brown skin. And he knows this because his mom said it is for sure, for sure. He does not like salad.
他会拼写“loss”（损失/失去）这个词。他妈妈的肚子鼓鼓的，因为里面有个宝宝。宝宝会有棕色的皮肤。他知道这一点是因为妈妈说了那是千真万确的。他不喜欢沙拉。
I do like the onions in it. I eat them a lot. But I do not eat the salad. I just eat the chicken, 'cause the chicken goes with the salad. And I don't eat the salad.
我确实喜欢里面的洋葱。我经常吃洋葱。但我不吃沙拉。我只吃鸡肉，因为鸡肉和沙拉配在一起。我不吃沙拉。
JJ just started kindergarten. I ask him what preschool was like before kindergarten. He tells me, "I was in green room with Miss Bethany and I-don't-remember-her-name lady. There were three racecars." More blocks than a number he knows.
JJ刚上幼儿园。我问他上幼儿园之前的学前班是什么样的。他告诉我：“我在Miss Bethany的绿色教室里，还有一个我不记得名字的女士。那里有三辆赛车。”积木多得数不过来。
Later, I talk to JJ's mom, Tunette Powell. And she told me a very different story about JJ's time in preschool. She says, last January, she was in the car on the way to a meeting.
后来，我采访了JJ的妈妈图内特·鲍威尔（Tunette Powell）。她告诉了我一个关于JJ学前班生活的截然不同的故事。她说，去年一月，她在开车去参加会议的路上。
They called my husband, and my husband called me. And my husband said, "We need to pick up JJ." And I said, "Pick him up?" And he said, "Yeah. They said he threw a chair and he needs to go home."
学校给我的丈夫打了电话，我丈夫又打给我。他说：“我们需要去接JJ。”我说：“接他？”他说：“是的。他们说他扔了一把椅子，他得回家。”
And I'm like, are you kidding? That he threw a chair? I'm not saying that he can't do anything, but he is the little guy who I worry about, because, even if him and his brother, who's two years younger than him, if his brother hits him, he will cry. Very, very sensitive and not very aggressive at all.
我想，你在开玩笑吗？他扔了椅子？我不是说他什么都干不出来，但他是个让我担心的胆小鬼，因为即使他那个小两岁的弟弟打他，他也会哭。他非常非常敏感，一点也不好斗。
Still, as she exited the highway, she did a special form of mental gymnastics I believe is familiar to parents everywhere.
尽管如此，当她从高速公路下来时，她进行了某种特殊的心理斗争，我相信所有家长都对此很熟悉。
You know, automatically, then you're thinking, wow, I failed as a parent. It was difficult.
你知道，你会下意识地想：哇，我作为一个家长失败了。那种感觉很艰难。
You went right there? You went to, I failed as a parent?
你直接就想到那儿去了？你想到的是：我作为家长失败了？
I did. That's immediately where I went.
是的。我立刻就这么想。
When Tunette got to the school, the woman at the front desk gave her a form that said JJ threw a chair. She asked Tunette to sign it. So she did.
当图内特赶到学校时，前台的女士给了她一张表格，上面写着JJ扔了椅子。她要求图内特签名。于是她签了。
We're not people who just say, oh, blame the school or blame the teacher or, oh, it's somebody else's problem. I mean, we immediately looked at what do we need to do to right the ship. This is not OK. I mean, we told him, you're going to go to your room. And I talked to him about everything.
我们不是那种只会责怪学校、责怪老师，或者认为那是别人问题的父母。我们立即反思我们需要做些什么来纠正航向。这不对劲。我们告诉他，你要去你的房间里待着。我还跟他谈了所有的事情。
And we thought, OK, he seems like he understood. And so I thought, OK, this is a one-time thing, never happen again. And then, in the same week, JJ was at school for about 30 minutes. And they called me.
我们以为，他看起来明白了。所以我以为这只是一次性的，再也不会发生了。结果，就在同一周，JJ在学校待了大约30分钟。他们又打电话给我。
They said that he had been crying at the breakfast table. And they didn't know why he was crying. That they kept asking him why he was crying, and he would not tell them why he was crying.
他们说他在早餐桌上一直在哭。他们不知道为什么。他们一直问他为什么哭，他就是不肯说。
And then he pushed a chair again. And neither of the times, he didn't hit anybody. But of course, he could have.
然后他又推了一次椅子。这两次他都没有打到任何人。但当然，他本可能会打到人。
JJ was sent to his room again. No cartoons, no fruit snacks. A couple weeks after that, JJ spit on another kid. He got sent home again.
JJ又被送回了房间。没有动画片，没有零食。几周后，JJ朝另一个孩子吐了口水。他又被遣送回家。
Tunette asked for more information this time. And there was a long back-and-forth about the definition of "spit on." It was not projectile; more like dribble.
这次图内特询问了更多信息。关于“吐口水”的定义，双方反复争论了很久。那根本不是喷射状的，更像是滴落。
And at home, they did the same routine-- you're going to go to your room, no treats. But Tunette worried JJ didn't seem to understand that, when he was bad at school, being sent home was a punishment. Tunette didn't think he got that connection.
在家时，他们重复同样的例行程序——去你的房间，没奖励。但图内特担心JJ根本不明白，当他在学校表现不好时，被送回家是一种惩罚。图内特觉得他不理解这种关联。
I don't. I think he almost saw it as a good thing, where, yes, it was sad, because Mommy wasn't happy with me. But at the same time, when I pick them up at school, they're not running away from me; they're running to me.
我不觉得他懂。我觉得他几乎把它看作是一件好事，是的，这很悲伤，因为妈妈对我没心情，但与此同时，我去学校接他们时，他们不是在躲我，而是在朝我奔来。
Do you know what a suspension is?
你知道什么是停课吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Have you heard that word before?
你以前听说过这个词吗？
Yes.
听过。
And what does it mean?
它是什么意思？
I forgot. But I do have Captain Damerica. He's the guy with the shield.
我忘了。但我有美国队长。就是那个拿着盾牌的家伙。
Captain what?
什么队长？
Captain Damerica.
美国队长。
So yeah, I don't think he got it. And of course he didn't. He was four years old at the time. To me, it sounds crazy to suspend a four-year-old. Like, there has got to be a better way to get your message across.
所以，是的，我觉得他没明白。当然他不会明白，他当时才四岁。对我来说，停课一个四岁孩子听起来太疯狂了。必须有更好的方式来传达你的要求。
It didn't seem like it was messing him up or anything. JJ didn't seem traumatized. It just didn't look like it was working.
这看起来并没有对他造成什么伤害之类的。JJ看起来并没有心理创伤。只是这看起来没用。
Then, after the third time he was suspended, Tunette started to feel like there was only one explanation for why it wasn't working. And it wasn't her parenting or the school. It wasn't JJ.
然后，在他第三次被停课后，图内特开始觉得，为什么管教没用，只有一个解释。那不是她的教养问题，也不是学校的问题，更不是JJ的问题。
It was her. She was a problem student when she was a kid. And she felt like, somehow, she passed that on to her son. She disrupted class a lot, got in fights.
是她自己。她小时候就是个问题学生。她觉得某种程度上，她把这一点遗传给了儿子。她上课时经常捣乱，还会打架。
I got in trouble all the time as a kid. I was suspended frequently. So when my kids started getting suspended, it's like--
我小时候一直惹麻烦。我经常被停课。所以当我的孩子们开始被停课时，就像是——
But you weren't suspended in preschool.
但你学前班时没被停课吧。
Yes. Yes. I was suspended and expelled from preschool. Mm-hm.
有，有的。我学前班时就被停课甚至开除了。嗯。
Like three, four years old?
就在三四岁的时候？
Yes. Absolutely. Absolutely. And so when I see my own kids getting suspended from school, you know, my kids are me. So I got in trouble a lot when I was little.
是的，绝对是。所以当我看到自己的孩子从学校被停课时，你知道，我的孩子就是我。我小时候确实经常惹麻烦。
My kids are me. Doesn't matter if the situation's different. It doesn't even matter. They're just me.
我的孩子就是我。情况是否不同并不重要。这根本无关紧要。他们就是我。
It had mattered greatly to Tunette that the situation would be different for her kids. She spent the last decade taking one enormous step after another away from her childhood. Her dad was in prison when she was a kid. Her children have a father. Her mom never had enough money.
对图内特来说，情况能为她的孩子们变得不同非常重要。在过去十年里，她一步一个脚印地远离了自己的童年。她小时候父亲在坐牢。她的孩子们有父亲。她母亲以前总缺钱。
She and her husband moved to Omaha so Tunette's husband could be in the Air Force. They have a steady income, four bedrooms, and a lawn. Tunette went into kindergarten knowing she was a bad kid. And she lived up to that reputation all the way through school.
她和丈夫搬到了奥马哈，这样丈夫就能在空军服役。他们有稳定的收入、四间卧室和一个院子。图内特上幼儿园时就知道自己是个坏孩子。在整个学生生涯中，她都在印证那个名声。
But my kids seem so different. They seem like-- my kids are so good. They're so happy. They're so full of life. They just seemed a lot different than I did at three or four.
但我的孩子们看起来完全不同。他们看起来——我的孩子们真好。他们很开心，充满活力。他们看起来和我三四岁时完全不同。
And they're so well-behaved at home and in public, when we go to restaurants and any of these places like that. Anywhere we take them, to the mall, anywhere, people are just always stopping us and saying, how are your kids so well behaved? So the fact that that was not very consistent at school just broke my heart.
而且他们在家里和公共场所表现得非常好，当我们去餐馆之类的地方时。无论我们带他们去哪儿，去商场，任何地方，人们总是停下来问我们：你的孩子们是怎么教得这么乖的？所以，这些在学校表现出的不一致性真的让我心碎。
A few weeks after JJ was first suspended, Tunette took him to a birthday party.
JJ第一次被停课几周后，图内特带他去参加了一个生日派对。
And this is where, at this point, remember, I'm feeling really low on myself, I guess my parenting skills. And so I go to this birthday party. And it's for his friend, one of his little friends.
就在那一点上，记住，我对自己的评价很低，尤其是对我的育儿技巧。所以我去了这个生日派对。那是他一个小朋友的。
And all the parents are kind of talking, all the women parents. And we're talking about the preschool. And some of them are saying things that they like and don't like and all these different things. And then I said, well, JJ's been suspended. And they were like, suspended? And I'm like, yeah.
所有的家长都在聊天，所有的妈妈们。我们讨论着学前班的事。有些人说他们喜欢什么不喜欢什么，诸如此类。然后我说，JJ被停课了。她们问，停课？我说，对。
And they said, they suspend kids? They were shocked. And I said, absolutely. I said, he's been suspended, and I started telling them all the things that he had done.
她们说，他们还给孩子停课？她们很震惊。我说，绝对有。我说，他被停课了，然后我开始讲他做过的所有事情。
And then one parent's like, I wonder why my kid hasn't been suspended. And I'm like, hm? What? So then she says, well, my son, he hit this kid on purpose, and they had to rush that kid to the hospital, and all I got was a phone call. And I was like, hm. And one after another, they kept telling me different stuff-- my kid did this, my kid did that, my kid bit somebody, my kid-- all these things.
然后一位家长说，我纳闷为什么我孩子没被停课。我说，嗯？什么？然后她说，哦，我儿子，他故意打了个孩子，他们不得不把那个孩子送进医院，我只接到一个电话。我当时心想，嗯。一个接一个，她们不断地告诉我各种事情——我孩子做了这个，我孩子做了那个，我孩子咬了人，我孩子——各种各样的事情。
And my kids, they're all the same age, all the same class. And only JJ had been sent home. So I was like, what is going on? That's when I thought to myself, something is not right.
而我的孩子们，年纪都一样，班级也一样。只有JJ被送回家了。所以我心想，到底怎么回事？就在那时我对自己说，有些地方不对劲。
The other parents were white at this birthday party?
那个生日派对上的其他家长是白人吗？
The other parents were white. It was three other parents and myself. And they were white. And where we live, the majority of the kids are white.
其他家长是白人。包括我在内一共四位家长。她们是白人。在我们住的地方，大多数孩子都是白人。
And I'm not a person who does that, oh, everything's against black people, or I don't wake up and look for situations where there's discrimination or racism or any of that. So I wasn't-- oh, they're just doing this because my kids are black. I had no reason to believe that. After that birthday party, it forced me to consider it.
我不是那种动不动就说，哦，一切都针对黑人的人，我也不会醒着就寻找歧视或种族主义之类的场景。所以我并没有——哦，他们只是因为我孩子是黑人才这样做。我没有理由相信这一点。但那个生日派对之后，它迫使我考虑这一点。
After the birthday party, Tunette's younger son, Joah, got suspended. Joah was three, though just barely three. He'd just had his birthday that week.
生日派对后，图内特的小儿子乔亚（Joah）也被停课了。乔亚当时三岁，刚满三岁。那周刚过完他的生日。
Tunette writes for a local Omaha parenting blog called Momaha. She wrote a post with the headline, "Is My Black Preschooler Just Another Statistic?"
图内特在当地一个奥马哈育儿博客“Momaha”上写作。她写了一篇文章，标题是：“我的黑人学前班儿子只是又一个统计数据吗？”
I reached out to the preschool. And they did not want to comment or even allow me to talk to the director of the school. But Tunette's post got picked up by the Washington Post . And she started getting dozens of messages, especially from black parents, all over the country.
我联系了那所学前班。他们不想评论，甚至不允许我与校长谈话。但图内特的文章被《华盛顿邮报》转载了。她开始收到全国各地几十个人的留言，特别是黑人家长。
In every part, every little sector, just saying that this has happened to me, and I thought I was by myself.
在每一个地方，每一个小圈子，他们都说这种事也发生在我身上，我原以为只有我自己遇到。
Tunette was very much not by herself. This is not a new conversation for lots of black and Latino parents noticing that their kids seem to be punished more harshly than white kids. That's not new.
图内特绝不是一个人在面对。对于许多黑人和拉丁裔家长来说，这并不是什么新鲜话题，他们注意到自己的孩子似乎比白人孩子受到更严厉的惩罚。这不新鲜。
What is new is that some academics and activists have been taking these stories and attaching them to a new, provocative term-- "the school-to-prison pipeline." The idea is that what's happening to Tunette's son is happening to lots of kids of color all over the country. And once those kids are old enough, the excessive punishment in school really messes them up and makes them much more likely to wind up in prison.
新鲜的是，一些学者和活动家已经开始采纳这些故事，并将其与一个新兴的、挑衅性的术语联系起来——“学校到监狱的管道”。其观点是，图内特儿子身上发生的事正在全国许多有色人种孩子身上发生。一旦这些孩子长大，学校里过度的惩罚真的会毁了他们，让他们更有可能最终进入监狱。
Yeah, you'd hear stories from advocates who would talk about a school-to-prison pipeline.
是的，你会听到倡导者讲述关于“学校到监狱管道”的故事。
Michael Thompson is the director of the Council of State Governments Justice Center. It's a nonpartisan think-tanky type place. And Thompson kept hearing that term, "school-to-prison pipeline."
迈克尔·汤普森（Michael Thompson）是州政府委员会司法中心（Council of State Governments Justice Center）的负责人。这是一个无党派的智库型机构。汤普森一直听到“学校到监狱管道”这个词。
His job is to advise lawmakers on crime policy. So he was getting asked a lot, is this a real thing? Are black and Latino kids really punished more in school and ending up in prison because of it? It seemed a little far-fetched to Michael Thompson.
他的工作是为立法者提供犯罪政策方面的建议。所以他经常被问到，这真的是一回事吗？黑人和拉丁裔孩子在学校里真的受到了更多的惩罚，并因此最终入狱吗？对迈克尔·汤普森来说，这似乎有点牵强。
Um, you know, I think everything's more complicated than that.
嗯，你知道，我认为一切都比这更复杂。
Thompson likes numbers. He enjoys being in close proximity to Microsoft Excel. And this is exactly the kind of assignment he does not like, because there are not consistent numbers on discipline in schools. Every school is different, every district, every state.
汤普森喜欢数据。他喜欢在Excel表格旁边工作。但这正是他最不喜欢的一类任务，因为关于学校管教的数据并不一致。每一所学校都不同，每一个学区、每一个州都不同。
And then, Michael Thompson learned about Texas. Texas, somewhat miraculously, had followed every single public school student from seventh grade through graduation-- the seventh graders of 2000, 2001, 2002. And they had documented everything-- report cards, if the kid was poor, Asian, switched schools, gotten in trouble, followed them all the way through graduation.
然后，迈克尔·汤普森了解到了德克萨斯州的情况。德克萨斯州奇迹般地跟踪了每一位公立学校学生从七年级到毕业的全过程——2000年、2001年、2002年的七年级学生。他们记录了一切——成绩单、孩子是否贫困、是否亚裔、是否转学、是否惹过麻烦，一直跟踪到毕业。
So Thomson could ask the researchers in College Station at Texas A&M, how many white kids were suspended? For what? How many times? Which schools?
所以汤普森可以问德克萨斯农工大学学院站的那些研究员：有多少白人学生被停课？因为什么？几次？哪些学校？
I was just-- all these numbers. The image I have is these guys in Texas A&M with white lab coats. We would joke that all the lights would dim in College Station each time they would run an analysis of this thing, because it was such a massive data set.
我只是——所有这些数字。我脑海中的形象是这些在德克萨斯农工大学穿着白色实验服的家伙。我们开玩笑说，每次他们运行分析时，学院站的灯光都会变暗，因为数据集实在太庞大了。
The lab coats peered down at a million students' lives-- the schools they attended, how they did, when they got in trouble. And they determined that African American and Hispanic students were twice as likely to receive an out-of-school suspension than their white peers for their first offense. When they looked at African American boys in Texas, 83% were suspended at least once. And usually, they were suspended a lot more than once. That includes anything a school calls suspension.
穿着实验服的人审视着一百万学生的生活——他们就读的学校、成绩表现、什么时候惹的麻烦。他们得出结论，非裔和拉丁裔学生因首次违纪而受到校外停课惩罚的可能性是其白人同伴的两倍。当他们审视德克萨斯州的非裔男孩时，83%的人至少被停课过一次。通常情况下，他们被停课的次数远不止一次。这包括学校称之为停课的所有情况。
But still, take 10 black boys, two of them made it through middle and high school without being suspended. And what kind of infractions were they getting suspended for? Most of the time, these were not for big things, like hitting a teacher or bringing a weapon to school. They were for things like disrespect, insubordination, willful defiance, the kind of incident that often begins when an angry kid won't take his hat off.
但即便如此，拿10个黑人男孩来说，只有两个在初中和高中阶段没有被停课。他们因为什么违规行为被停课？大多数情况下，这些并非大事，比如打老师或带武器去学校。他们是因为诸如不尊重、不服从、故意挑衅等原因——那种通常始于一个愤怒的孩子不肯摘下帽子时的冲突。
OK, and one more striking thing you can see in the Texas numbers-- kids who were suspended were much more likely to be arrested outside of school, three times as likely to come into contact with the juvenile justice system.
好，德克萨斯州的数据中还有一个引人注目的现象——那些被停课的孩子在校外被捕的可能性要大得多，他们与少年司法系统接触的可能性是其他人的三倍。
To be honest, it was a little bit of a spine-tingling moment, because I kept thinking about how city advocates had been saying this is such a common event. And my instant reaction was, this is going to give a whole lot more credibility to this conversation than we've ever had before.
说实话，那一刻我有点背脊发凉，因为我一直想到城市倡导者们一直在说这是一件非常普遍的事情。我的第一反应是，这将给这场对话带来前所未有的可信度。
They're right. I mean, what you're saying is you've just found that they're right.
他们是对的。我的意思是，你所说的是你刚刚发现他们是对的。
Yeah. At that point, that's right.
是的。在那一点上，没错。
The idea of suspending a young person for bad behavior-- what is that? A kid who's disrespectful or insubordinate does not want to be in class. So you suspend them? Just saying that out loud, that sounds weird, right?
因为不良行为而对年轻人停课——那是什么？一个不尊重人或不服从的孩子不想上课。所以你就让他停课？光是把这句话大声说出来，听起来就很奇怪，对吧？
A couple years ago, the state of Maryland wrote a law-- state legislator sat down and wrote this law-- that says you cannot suspend students for being truant. If a kid skips school, you can't punish him by telling him, you can't come to school. They needed a law to make that clear.
几年前，马里兰州写了一项法律——州议员坐下来写了这项法律——规定不能因为旷课而停课。如果孩子逃学，你不能通过告诉他“你不准来学校”来惩罚他。他们需要一项法律来明确这一点。
I talked to a sociologist named Pedro Noguera who told me that, over the last few decades, suspensions have become the go-to move in response to disruptive behavior, for everyone, actually, but especially black and Hispanic kids.
我采访了一位名叫佩德罗·诺格拉（Pedro Noguera）的社会学家，他告诉我，在过去的几十年里，停课已经成为应对破坏性行为的常用手段，对所有人都是如此，实际上，尤其针对黑人和拉丁裔孩子。
Denying them learning time, which is, I think, the most ridiculous part of it.
剥夺他们的学习时间，我认为这是最荒谬的部分。
And because of the Texas numbers, we now know that those same kids are at a much higher risk of being arrested. So is there a connection here? One way to look at this is just that our society gives tougher punishments to black and Hispanic kids when they are JJ's age, when they're in preschool, and when they're in high school, and when they're old enough to go to prison. The issue is not school. It's just racism.
而且因为德克萨斯州的数据，我们现在知道同样的孩子被捕的风险要高得多。所以这之间有联系吗？一种看待这件事的方式是，我们的社会在孩子们JJ这个年纪、在学前班时、在高中时，以及当他们到了可以进监狱的年纪时，对黑人和拉丁裔孩子给予了更严厉的惩罚。问题不在于学校，而在于种族主义。
But Noguera says school is an important part of this picture. And here's the theory he laid out for me. You suspend a kid, he misses school, he finds it hard to catch up, he feels frustrated, falls behind. And maybe just as important, he learns he is bad. Because he feels bad when he's in school, he acts bad.
但诺格拉说，学校是这幅图景的重要组成部分。这是他向我提出的理论。你让一个孩子停课，他错过了学校课程，发现很难跟上，感到沮丧，落后了。而可能同样重要的是，他学会了自己是个坏孩子。因为他在学校感到糟糕，所以他表现得糟糕。
There's this assumption that, if we get rid of the bad people, that the good people will be able to learn, the good people will be safe. What we continue to ignore is that we are producing the bad people. We're producing in school the bad behavior.
有一种假设认为，如果我们除掉了坏人，好人就能够学习，好人就安全了。我们继续忽视的是，我们正在制造坏人。我们正在学校里制造不良行为。
Producing it through the system of punishment that convinces some kids that they're bad.
通过惩罚体系制造它，让一些孩子确信自己是坏孩子。
In May, 2011, Michael Thompson got a meeting with the Attorney General of the United States. And he showed him the Texas numbers. And two months later, the Attorney General and the Secretary of Education were standing together at a press conference about discipline in schools. They started gathering their own numbers from schools, all over the country this time. And those numbers were worse, even in preschool.
2011年5月，迈克尔·汤普森与美国司法部长会面，并向他展示了德克萨斯州的数据。两个月后，司法部长和教育部部长一起站在新闻发布会上，谈论学校管教问题。这一次，他们开始从全国各地的学校收集自己的数据。而那些数据更糟糕，甚至在学前班里也是如此。
In March this year, the Department of Education issued a report that said black children make up 18% of preschoolers, but they make up 48% of preschool children suspended more than once.
今年3月，教育部发布了一份报告，称黑人儿童占学前班学生的18%，但他们占被多次停课学前班儿童的48%。
When I found that, it was the same month as the birthday party. And I saw the story and the way it just said that black children are suspended at much higher rates. So I'm thinking to myself, in the same few months that my kids were being suspended, I go to this birthday party, and then I see this report.
当我发现这一点时，那正好是生日派对后的那个月。我看到了这个故事，看到它说黑人儿童被停课的比例要高得多。所以我自己心想，就在我的孩子被停课的那几个月里，我去参加了这个生日派对，然后看到了这份报告。
I asked Tunette what the report meant to her. And she found it hard to summarize so many things.
我问图内特这份报告对她意味着什么。她觉得很难总结这么多东西。
First, when I saw the report, it made me feel like my kids were a target. It just felt like they were a target. I felt like my kids-- is this something that I have to worry about forever? Is this not something that I could just say was this one-time little thing? It's like something that I'll always have to be aware of and always have to think about and always have to be more involved than the next parent in my kids' lives at school because of these studies.
首先，当我看到报告时，它让我觉得我的孩子是目标。感觉他们就是目标。我觉得我的孩子——这是我必须永远担心的事情吗？这不是我可以称之为“那件一次性的小事”吗？这就像是我必须永远意识到，永远考虑，而且因为这些研究，我必须比其他家长更多地参与到孩子们在学校的生活中。
And then, second, the report just kind of made me feel like maybe I wasn't as bad.
然后，其次，这份报告只是让我觉得，也许我并没有那么坏。
She's talking about herself there, as a kid. Remember, Tunette was a problem student herself, preschool through high school graduation.
她在这里谈论她自己，作为孩子时的她。记住，图内特自己就是从学前班到高中毕业的问题学生。
Maybe I could have been-- maybe, since there's such this overwhelming number, maybe that meant that the teachers weren't always doing the right thing.
也许我可以——也许，既然有如此惊人的数字，也许那意味着老师们并不总是做得对。
Even as she's saying that, Tunette isn't quite sure she believes it. She remembers being bad. She flipped over a desk in class one time. That happened. But she also remembers that, after getting suspended in preschool, she walked into kindergarten fully convinced the teacher was the enemy. And that never went away.
即使在说这些时，图内特也不确定她是否真的相信。她记得自己表现很坏。她有一次在课堂上翻过桌子。那确实发生过。但她也记得，在学前班被停课后，她走进幼儿园时完全确信老师是敌人。那种感觉从未消失。
All those times she was suspended, she didn't come back less angry, ready to obediently follow directions. It was the opposite. Tunette says, "I went into kindergarten knowing I was bad. I went into first grade knowing I was terrible. And it just went up from there."
所有她被停课的那些时间里，她回来时并没有变得少一些愤怒，也没有准备好服从指挥。恰恰相反。图内特说：“我走进幼儿园时就知道自己是个坏孩子。我走进一年级时就知道自己糟透了。情况只会愈演愈烈。”
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, two ambitious, totally interesting, and completely opposite attempts to do discipline differently in schools. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。接下来，是两个雄心勃勃、非常有趣且截然不同的尝试，旨在改变学校的管教方式。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时在一分钟内为您带来报道。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, discipline in schools-- is it working? Is it messing kids up? One of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has been looking into that for months.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是学校管教——它有效吗？它在毁掉孩子吗？我们的制片人之一查娜·乔夫-沃尔特已经研究这个问题好几个月了。
And in this half of our program, we look at two approaches to discipline that teachers are trying in schools in poor, urban neighborhoods. There's a pattern that teachers see in a lot of these schools. The pattern is this-- the kids walk in on day one, they're already stressed out by the environments they come from, and they act out. So they get punished.
在本期节目的后半部分，我们看看老师们在贫困城市街区的学校里尝试的两种管教方法。在这些学校里，老师们看到了一个模式。这个模式是：孩子们第一天走进教室时，就已经因为他们所处的环境而感到压力重重，他们表现出了挑衅。于是他们受到了惩罚。
They get the message that they're bad. They come to hate school. They act out some more.
他们得到的信息是：他们是坏孩子。他们开始讨厌学校。他们表现得更加挑衅。
I had a kid throw a bathroom stall door out the window from the third floor. And I got in trouble, because I let him go to the bathroom.
有个孩子从三楼的窗户扔出了一个卫生间隔断门。我惹了大麻烦，因为我让他去了洗手间。
Katie Furr first taught at a middle school in New York City in Washington Heights with tons of kids who acted out. There were fights.
凯蒂·弗尔（Katie Furr）最初在纽约华盛顿高地的一所中学教书，那里有大量表现出挑衅的孩子。打架斗殴常有发生。
It didn't really feel like anybody was in charge, except this one eighth grader. He actually yelled down the hall one day, "I run this mother." And I realized he did.
感觉没人管事，除了这一个八年级的孩子。有一天，他甚至在走廊里大喊：“我统治这里。”我意识到他说的是真的。
Often, she would just lose control of her class because of this kid named Christopher, a curly-haired 14-year-old with braces who gave her more trouble than anybody else in the class. Like one day, Christopher left class to go to the bathroom. And Ms. Furr took his coat. And she locked it in a closet with all the other kids' coats. There was a school policy in that school to lock up coats like that to make it harder for the kids to leave school in the middle of the day.
通常，她会因为这个叫克里斯托弗（Christopher）的孩子而无法控制课堂。他是一个14岁、戴着牙套的卷发男孩，比班上任何人都让她头疼。比如有一天，克里斯托弗离开教室去洗手间。弗尔老师拿走了他的外套，并把它锁在了一个装有其他孩子外套的壁橱里。学校有一项政策，把外套锁起来，以免孩子在白天中途离开学校。
He came back in, and he was like, where's my coat? And one of the other kids was like, Ms. Furr locked it in the closet. And he was like, you steal my stuff, I'm going to steal your stuff.
他回来后问：“我的外套在哪儿？”其他孩子之一说：“弗尔老师把它锁在壁橱里了。”他说：“你偷我的东西，我就去偷你的东西。”
He walked over to my desk. He's taking staplers, he's throwing papers. He's like, throwing stuff around the room. He's putting stuff in his backpack, in his pockets.
他走到我的桌子旁，拿起订书机，乱扔纸张。他像是在房间里四处乱扔东西。他把东西塞进书包、口袋里。
And the security guard came in, and he didn't really know what to do. And I mean, Christopher's running circles around the security guard, my Post-Its falling out of his pants pocket. It was just ridiculous.
保安进来了，他真的不知道该怎么办。我的意思是，克里斯托弗绕着保安跑圈，我的便利贴从他的裤兜里掉出来。这太荒唐了。
In reaction to the kind of chaotic public school where learning is interrupted a lot and so kids fall further behind, two decades ago, some teachers launched one of the biggest recent experiments in American education, a whole movement of charter schools designed for poor minority kids. The idea is that the classrooms are rigorous, high standards, long school days. When it comes to discipline, they are strict, they're orderly, they are hyper-vigilant. There's a slogan they use-- they sweat the small stuff, so things never get to the point they did in Ms. Furr's class.
为了应对那种学习经常被中断、导致孩子进一步落后的混乱公立学校，二十年前，一些老师发起了一项美国教育界最近最大的实验——一场为贫困少数族裔孩子设计的特许学校运动。其理念是：教室严谨、高标准、上课时间长。在管教方面，他们严格、有序、高度警惕。他们使用一个口号——他们关注琐碎细节，所以事情永远不会发展到弗尔老师班上那种地步。
These kinds of charter schools have now been around long enough that the first generation of students who went through them are grown. And some of those students now look back on their time in those schools. And they think about, did it work? What worked? What didn't work?
这些特许学校现在已经存在足够长的时间，以至于第一代在那里就读的学生已经长大。其中一些学生现在回首他们在那些学校的时光。他们思考着：这奏效了吗？什么奏效了？什么没奏效？
In this act, Act Two-- we're calling this act "The Guinea Pig Becomes the Scientist"-- Chana talked with one of those students who grew up and decided to become a teacher himself.
在这一幕，第二幕——我们称之为“小白鼠变成了科学家”——查娜采访了其中一名长大后决定成为老师的学生。
Being a human subject is a thing that ranks pretty high on Rousseau Mieze's "who I am" list. He grew up in Roxbury, Mass. His parents are Haitian immigrants. And at age 10 years old, Rousseau became a human test subject when his mom signed him up to be part of the first sixth-grade class at the Academy of the Pacific Rim.
作为人类受试者是卢梭·米泽（Rousseau Mieze）在“我是谁”的列表中排名很高的一件事。他在马萨诸塞州罗克斯伯里长大。他的父母是海地移民。10岁那年，当妈妈给他报名参加太平洋边缘学院（Academy of the Pacific Rim）的第一届六年级班时，卢梭成了一名人类受试者。
I like to think of it as first generation charter school. Students are silent. Students are sitting up straight. There's just no room in a classroom for students not following directions or following the rules or doing what they are asked to do. And version 1.0 of that was, like, my second day of school, I got suspended, sent home, because I celebrated-- because I got 100 on a math quiz, one of those Math Minutes.
我喜欢把它看作第一代特许学校。学生保持沉默，学生坐得笔直。教室里根本没有容忍学生不服从指令、不遵守规则或不完成任务的空间。那套1.0版本的教学方式让我入学第二天就因为庆祝而被停课了——因为我在数学测验中得了100分，那种“数学分钟”测验。
You got suspended for celebrating a math--
你因为庆祝数学测验被停课——
For talking, talking out of turn.
因为说话，轮到我说话了。
Wait. What'd you say?
等等。你说了什么？
"Yes! Yes! I got 100 on my Math Minutes." But I said it out loud.
“耶！耶！我数学分钟得了100分。”但我说得很大声。
Suspension?
停课？
Yeah.
对。
Rousseau's teachers had spent years coming up with the theories that created that first week of school. They wanted to close the achievement gap with long school days and high expectations. They have lots of slogans-- no excuses, zero tolerance for misbehavior. And Rousseau's teachers believed this approach would motivate the kids to behave. Which it did, for some kids. And for some kids, it did not.
卢梭的老师们花了几年时间构思出创造了那个开学第一周的理论。他们希望通过长教学时间和高期望来缩小成就差距。他们有很多口号——没有借口，对违纪零容忍。而卢梭的老师们相信这种方法会激励孩子们表现良好。确实，对一些孩子来说有效。但对另一些孩子来说，则不然。
I was definitely one of the-- how to put this? I got in trouble a lot, like, a lot. And so--
我绝对是那些——怎么说呢？我经常惹麻烦，真的非常多。所以——
What kinds of things were you doing?
你做了哪些事？
Impulse control. Talking. Talking, talking, talking, talking, talking. Yeah, that was most of it.
冲动控制。说话。不停地说话、说话、说话。是的，大部分就是这些。
A few of Rousseau's childhood teachers went on to start their own schools, went on to scale up their vision of rigorous, no-excuses schools for America's poor and minority students. Rousseau's former teachers now write books and talk about the mistakes they made early on and all the important lessons they took from those mistakes, things like, don't shame students by making them stand with their nose to the chalkboard for the rest of the class. Don't make them bark like a dog. It is not best practice to throw chairs in order to get kids to see you're serious. And when a kid is late, do not do what a teacher did to Rousseau.
卢梭童年时的一些老师后来创办了自己的学校，将他们那套严谨、无借口的学校愿景扩展到全美国的贫困和少数族裔学生身上。卢梭的前老师们现在写书，谈论他们早年犯下的错误以及他们从这些错误中吸取的所有重要教训，比如：不要通过让学生站在黑板前罚站来羞辱他们；不要让他们像狗一样叫；为了让孩子知道你是认真的，扔椅子绝非最佳实践。当孩子迟到时，千万不要做某位老师对卢梭做过的事。
He's like, where were you? [MIMICKING YELLING] And I'm like, sorry. I didn't realize-- and then he's like, get out He yells at me and screams at me to leave the classroom.
他问：“你去哪儿了？”[模仿大喊] 我说：“对不起，我没意识到——”然后他大喊：“滚出去！”他向我大吼大叫，喝令我离开教室。
And then I get up, and I'm walking. And he goes, walk faster! And screams at me to walk faster. I was so distraught, breathing heavy, crying, just uncontrollable anger and rage at that time. It felt like that.
然后我站起来走，他喊道：“走快点！”并尖叫着命令我走快点。我当时非常心烦意乱，呼吸急促，哭泣，在那一刻感到了无法控制的愤怒和狂暴。感觉就是那样。
You're still mad about it.
你对此仍然感到生气。
I'm really angry about it, like really angry about it. To this day, I can't say this guy's name. I can't even-- yeah. It's really bad.
我真的对此非常愤怒，就像非常愤怒。直到今天，我连这个人的名字都说不出口。我甚至不能——是的。真的很糟糕。
For Rousseau, there was a big upside to his charter school experience. He got into college. He doesn't think that would have happened otherwise. And it gave him the life he has today.
对卢梭来说，他的特许学校经历有一个巨大的好处。他考上了大学。他认为如果不去那所学校，那是不会发生的。它给了他今天的生活。
But there were downsides, too. For one, lots of kids couldn't hack it, left the school. Less than half of Rousseau's sixth grade class stayed till graduation. And some of the charter movement's leaders say too many of those who did make it to college ended up dropping out. One reason for that-- after all the strict control in high school, they floundered when they had no structure in college.
但也有负面影响。首先，很多孩子适应不了，离开了学校。卢梭六年级班中只有不到一半人坚持到毕业。而且一些特许学校运动的领导者表示，那些最终考上大学的人中，退学的比例太高了。原因之一——在经历了高中严苛的控制后，他们在大学里缺乏结构时陷入了挣扎。
When Rousseau aged out of being a human test subject, he pretty much immediately moved over to the other side and became a teacher. He got his first gig when he was still in college, a sort of teaching internship at a charter school in Rochester. He was 21 years old. And he finally had the distance to see things from the outside. He chaperoned his first field trip to DC, and it kind of freaked him out.
当卢梭过了做人类受试者的年纪后，他几乎立刻转到了另一边，成为了一名教师。他还在上大学时就得到了第一份工作，那是罗切斯特一所特许学校的实习教学职位。他当时21岁。他终于有了距离感，可以从外部看问题。他带了第一次去华盛顿的实地考察，那真的把他吓坏了。
And it was just so intense. Kids were single-file lines out of buses, single-file lines lined up in front of a bathroom at a rest stop. Monitors had to go into the bathrooms. Kids had to silently use the bathrooms, wash their hands.
而且它真的太紧张了。孩子们排着单行队伍下车，在休息站的洗手间前排着单行队伍。督导员不得不进入洗手间。孩子们必须安静地使用洗手间、洗手。
And Rousseau noticed that the kids were getting noticed. Grownups around them were smiling, pointing them out.
卢梭注意到孩子们受到了关注。周围的大人们在微笑，指着他们。
I think that there's some of it that's just like, kids and teenagers? Wow, I've never seen a group of teenagers silently walk into a bathroom, because who sees that? But also, I think there's a race thing that plays in there, too, where you're like, wow, look at a group of minority children in a rest stop, sort of, like, behaving.
我想其中一些原因只是因为——那是孩子和青少年？哇，我从没见过一群青少年安静地走进洗手间，因为谁见过那个？但我也认为这其中存在种族因素，你会想，哇，看看休息站那群少数族裔孩子，在那种……表现得乖巧的样子。
Rousseau was good with kids, especially the problem kids. When he graduated from college, he got a job through his charter connections. And Rousseau proceeded to be maybe the only rookie teacher in America who did not struggle with classroom management. Seriously, he was a genius at controlling the kids. The thing Rousseau struggled with was letting go of control.
卢梭很擅长带孩子，尤其是问题孩子。大学毕业后，通过他在特许学校的人脉，他找到了一份工作。卢梭成为了美国为数不多的几个在课堂管理方面没有挣扎的新手老师之一。说真的，他在控制孩子方面是个天才。卢梭挣扎的是放开控制。
By this point, the strict charters had pulled back some on the extreme discipline model. The slogans were still "zero tolerance," "no excuses." But Rousseau also heard a new one-- "power versus purpose." Make sure, when you are exerting your power, there's a reason for it.
到了这一点，严厉的特许学校已经在极端管教模式上有所退缩。口号仍然是“零容忍”、“没有借口”。但卢梭也听到了一个新的口号——“权力与目的”。确保你在施展权力时，是有原因的。
Is there a reason kids need to walk quietly into a rest stop on a field trip? Is there a reason you need that kid to unpack his bookbag silently? There might be. But you know, ask the question. Rousseau said school felt so different than he remembered.
孩子们去实地考察时有必要安静地走进休息站吗？有必要让那个孩子默默地整理书包吗？或许有。但你知道，多问问原因。卢梭说，学校感觉和他记忆中非常不同。
I saw kids laugh and have fun in school. I saw kids learn about commas through-- like one of my coworkers, Angar, he came in as Barack O-comma. And I saw that. I experienced students learn and did really well on the Rhode Island state test, killed the state. But they were having such a good time.
我在学校里看到孩子们大笑和享受乐趣。我看到孩子们通过——比如我的一个同事，安加，他化身为“奥巴马逗号”（Barack O-comma），我看到了这些。我体验了学生们学习，并在罗德岛州考试中表现非常出色，简直是横扫。但他们过得非常愉快。
And was that the first time that you had seen that?
那是你第一次看到那样吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it was.
是的。是的，确实是。
And you were like, oh, my god, school can be this way.
你当时一定在想：天哪，学校可以是这样的。
It can be fun. And it was crazy to me.
它可以很有趣。这对我很疯狂。
Rousseau and I talked in a small workroom at a school. And he had to interrupt our interview, because he said he needed to help with a transition. I didn't know what that meant, but I followed him into the hallway. And about 30 kids walked single-file line, completely silently, out of their classroom, down the hall, down three flights of stairs, to lunch. This is what that sounds like.
我和卢梭在学校的一间小工作室内谈话。他不得不打断采访，因为他说他需要协助一次“过渡”。我不知道那是什么意思，但我跟着他走进了走廊。大约30个孩子排成单行，完全安静地走出教室，沿着走廊，下三层楼梯，去吃午饭。听起来是这样的。
[CLAP]
[拍手声]
30 or so 11- and 12-year-old children are streaming past me, down the stairs, single-file. No arms are flapping, no mouths are open, no one is tripping or falling, all the way to the cafeteria.
大约30个11、12岁的孩子从我身边流过，下楼，排成单行。没有人挥舞手臂，没有人在说话，没有人绊倒或跌倒，一直流向餐厅。
That was a pretty silent line.
那排队伍真是安静。
Yeah, well, somebody earned a demerit for talking in that line.
是的，好吧，有人因为在队伍里说话而得到了一个违纪记录。
Somebody earned a demerit just now?
刚才有人得了一个记录？
From me, yeah. For talking.
从我这儿，是的。因为说话。
I did not hear any talking.
我没听到有人说话。
I listened back to try to find the infraction. And I think it must be this.
我回放听了听试图找出违规的地方。我觉得一定是这个。
[INAUDIBLE] demerit for talking.
[音频模糊] 因说话而记录。
Yeah. That creepy feeling Rousseau had watching the kids at the rest stop, I had that feeling. And it was super confusing, because Rousseau had just spent an hour telling me about these eye-opening experiences he'd had seeing kids laugh and Barack O-comma and how he could never stay quiet as a kid.
是的。卢梭看着那些休息站里的孩子时感到的那种毛骨悚然的感觉，我也有。这太令人困惑了，因为卢梭刚刚花了一个小时向我讲述他看到的那些开眼界的体验：孩子们大笑、奥巴马逗号，以及他自己小时候是怎么都安静不下来的。
So we talked about this for a while. And he says he's ambivalent about how controlling his school was, about all the ways his school today is a lot like the school he attended as a kid. But the longer he teaches, he says, the better he understands a thing that he did not get as a kid about why his teachers were so harsh. And that is that they were scared.
所以我们聊了很久。他说他对自己的学校控制得有多严感到矛盾，对今天他所在的学校在很多方面和他小时候上的学校很像感到困惑。但他教书的时间越长，他说，他就越理解小时候他不明白的、为什么老师们那么苛刻的原因。那就是：他们害怕。
They were scared of losing control of the class. He knew that. That part was obvious to him even when he was a teenager. But what he didn't realize at the time was they were also scared for him. He knows this now, because he is a teacher of mostly poor, mostly black students, like he was. And he feels this for his students.
他们害怕失去对班级的控制。他知道这一点。即使他十几岁时，那一部分对他来说也是显而易见的。但他当时没有意识到的是，他们也为他感到害怕。他现在知道了，因为他现在教的大多数是贫困的、黑人学生，就像他当年一样。他为他的学生感到担忧。
He's afraid for their well-being. He's afraid of the odds they will not graduate. He's afraid they won't get to college, afraid they'll get suspended or arrested for horsing around or being rowdy at the wrong place at the wrong time. So Rousseau finds himself saying things teachers said to him. And it's like when you're a parent and you hear your mother's voice coming out of your mouth, and you know what you are saying is such a worthless thing to say to a child, but you say it anyway.
他害怕他们的福祉。他害怕他们无法毕业的几率。他害怕他们进不了大学，害怕他们因为在错误的地方、错误的时间胡闹或吵闹而被停课或逮捕。所以卢梭发现自己说着老师曾经对他说过的话。这就像当你做了父母，听到母亲的声音从自己嘴里冒出来，你知道你对孩子说的话是多么毫无意义，但你还是说了。
Do you not get why I'm on this level? Let me get you on the level that I'm on. This is why I'm freaking out right now. I'm so worried, because I look at them, and I see myself, or I see my friends. You know, some of those people are in prison right now.
你不明白我为什么要达到这个水平吗？让我把你提升到我所在的水平。这就是为什么我现在要疯了。我非常担心，因为我看着他们，我看到了自己，或者我看到了我的朋友。你知道，有些人现在正在监狱里。
Rousseau wants to be able to loosen his grip some as a teacher, allow kids more freedom. He's trying to do that. He takes tiny steps. But he says his fear gets in the way.
卢梭作为一名教师，希望能够放松一些他的掌控，让孩子们有更多的自由。他正在尝试那样做。他采取微小的步骤。但他说，他的恐惧阻碍了他。
Act Three, "The Talking Cure." So after the Texas numbers came out, and then more studies and punishments in schools, lots of educators and policymakers became convinced that a lot of the discipline that schools administer is not working, especially suspensions. So if you don't want to suspend kids, what do you do instead?
第三幕，“谈话疗法”。所以，在德克萨斯州的数据出来之后，以及更多关于学校惩罚的研究之后，许多教育工作者和政策制定者变得确信，学校实施的许多管教措施并没有奏效，尤其是停课。所以，如果你不想让孩子停课，你该做什么？
Well, one alternative that's talked about a lot, that the Obama administration and others are pushing for schools, is something called restorative justice. Now, the model for this comes from the criminal justice system, where offenders and victims will sit down in a mediation, and they basically try to talk it out and find a way to restore the harm done by the crime. That's why it's restorative.
好吧，被讨论得很多、奥巴马政府和其他人正在推动的一种替代方案是“恢复性司法”。这种模式源自刑事司法体系，受害者和加害者坐下来进行调解，基本上他们试着谈出来，并找到一种修复犯罪造成伤害的方法。这就是为什么它是“恢复性的”。
So if this is the answer for schools, we wanted to see what it looks like when you try that in a school setting. Chana spent last spring semester at a public school called Lyons Community School in Brooklyn. It's a small middle and high school founded nearly eight years ago to attempt this approach with kids.
如果这是学校的答案，我们想看看当你在学校环境中尝试这种做法时会是什么样子。查娜在布鲁克林的里昂社区学校（Lyons Community School）度过了上个春季学期。这是一所成立近八年的小型中学和高中，旨在用这种方式对待孩子。
Just a quick note, the kids in this story are minors, and some of the names have been changed. Also, if you're listening to this on the internet or on podcast, there is cursing that we have not beeped in what you're about to hear. If you prefer a beeped version of our program, you can get it at our website, thisamericanlife.org. OK, here's Chana.
快速说明一下，这个故事中的孩子都是未成年人，一些名字已被更改。此外，如果您是在网上或通过播客收听，接下来听到的内容中有未被“哔”声屏蔽的咒骂。如果您更喜欢屏蔽后的版本，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 获取。好，请听查娜的报道。
I was popular at Lyons. It was a problem. Kids would see me walking around with my microphone, international symbol that someone is about to be made famous. And there'd be a scramble.
我在里昂很受欢迎。这是一个问题。孩子们会看到我带着麦克风走来走去，这是某人即将成名的国际符号。然后会有一场争夺。
Is this an interview?
这是一次采访吗？
Some very quick process of natural selection would take place, a dozen kids would get pushed aside, and I'd be left standing with the champions.
会发生一些非常快速的自然选择过程，一打孩子会被推到一边，我会被留下来和胜出者在一起。
So you guys are both what grade at Lyons?
所以你们两个在里昂读几年级？
Ninth.
九年级。
How do you like it?
你们喜欢这里吗？
It's good.
还不错。
Are you going to say everything at the same time?
你们俩是要同时说每一句话吗？
No. Stop!
不。停下！
You guys both started this year?
你们俩都是今年开始读的？
Yeah.
是的。
Having to move a conversation like this into an interview about restorative justice was a little bit of a bummer. Kids at Lyons don't necessarily know that term, nor do they want to talk about it. But when you ask them what their school is like, they have a lot to say about that, mostly what it feels like here. The teachers listen to you. And we have a voice.
被迫将这样的对话转变为关于恢复性司法的采访有点扫兴。里昂的孩子们不一定知道那个术语，他们也不想谈论它。但当你问他们学校是什么样时，他们有很多话要说，大多是关于在这里的感觉。老师们倾听你的想法，我们有发言权。
In my old middle school, they would just suspend us and whatever, call it a day. But at Lyons, we talk about the problem and stuff like that.
在我以前的中学，他们只会让我们停课等等，然后就结束了。但在里昂，我们讨论问题，诸如此类。
I had one little altercation, but me and the girl are friends now.
我以前有过一次小争执，但我跟那个女孩现在是朋友了。
Because we all talked about the situation. It was stupid. After the fight, we all got in a circle, and we just talked about the situation.
因为我们都谈论了那个情况。这很蠢。打架后，我们围成一圈，只是讨论了情况。
Circles. That's a big thing here. They sit in circles after a fight. Circles are where conflict is resolved, consequences are discussed, feelings are shared. The kids at Lyons get the message that talking is how you are successful.
圆圈。这是这里的一件大事。他们打架后会坐成圆圈。圆圈是解决冲突的地方，后果在这里讨论，感受在这里分享。里昂的孩子们得到的信息是：谈话才是你成功的方式。
A beefy ninth grader named Alex, with an Afro and dimples, walked me through, in detail, how he calms himself down when he gets frustrated in class. And then he told me, "Lyons is what made me." I ask him what he means by that.
一个叫亚历克斯（Alex）、身材魁梧、留着非裔发型有酒窝的九年级学生，详细地向我讲述了他在课上感到沮丧时是如何让自己冷静下来的。然后他告诉我，“里昂造就了我。”我问他那是什么意思。
I wouldn't think I would talk to you now how I'm talking to you.
如果以前，我不敢想象我会像现在这样跟你说话。
What do you mean, the way that you're talking to me now?
你是什么意思，你现在跟我说话的方式？
Like so friendly, like I could keep on talking and talking. If I would have never been at Lyons, I probably would have never been comfortable talking to you.
比如这么友好，比如我可以一直说下去。如果我从未在里昂，我可能永远不会习惯跟你说话。
You wouldn't even be sitting here with me.
你甚至不会坐在这里跟我说话。
No.
不。
You just would have walked away when I asked to talk to you.
当我请求和你交谈时，你只会走开。
I probably would have, yeah.
我可能会走开，是的。
Later, Alex told me, "I wouldn't have walked away nicely, either." His teachers confirmed this.
后来，亚历克斯告诉我：“我也不会礼貌地走开。”他的老师们证实了这一点。
All this talking at Lyons can just look like total chaos. There are kids in the hallway at Lyons all the time, there are fights, there's random screaming in between classes. Rousseau's charter school had zero tolerance. Lyons has a tolerance for disruption that rivals a paintball arena.
在里昂，所有这些谈话看起来就像完全的混乱。里昂的走廊里总是有孩子，有打架，课间有随机的尖叫声。卢梭的特许学校实行零容忍。里昂对干扰的容忍度堪比彩弹射击竞技场。
One day, I found a teacher and dean trying to game out how to approach a student who told a female teacher to suck his dick. The kid said this in class and then walked out.
有一天，我发现一位老师和训导主任正在研究如何处理一名告诉一位女老师“吸我下体”的学生。那个孩子在课堂上说了这些话，然后走了出去。
Were you mad? Like mad at him?
你当时生气吗？就是生他的气？
I just feel so bad for him, that he can't control himself. Why is he yelling at me? I've only ever been on his side. What is up with that? It just makes me so sad. I don't really have it in me to get mad at him about it.
我只是对他感到很难过，因为他无法控制自己。他为什么要对我大喊大叫？我一直都站在他这一边。那到底是怎么回事？这只是让我很难过。我真的没有力气因为这件事生他的气。
Even though he's telling you, "Suck my dick?"
尽管他告诉你，“吸我的下体”？
Well, that was just like a performance. I really didn't take it personally. I mean, it was really just kind of like--
嗯，那只是一种表演。我真的没有把它当作针对我个人。我的意思是，那真的只是一种类似——
Like out of the probably about 100 times somebody's told me to suck their dick, I don't think they ever meant it personally toward me.
就像有人大概一百次告诉我要吸他们的下体，我不觉得他们真的是针对我个人。
That's happened to you 100 times?
那种事发生过一百次？
Probably.
大概吧。
These two teachers talk about what it means that the student said those words for an hour. They then speak with the student for another hour, the student and his mom, the student and other students, the student one-on-one again. It is a thorough investigation into the meaning and effect of the words "Suck my dick" on the kid, on the teacher, and on the class.
这两位老师花了一个小时讨论那个学生说那些话意味着什么。他们然后与那个学生谈了一个小时，那个学生和他妈妈，那个学生和其他学生，那个学生再一对一一次。这是一次彻底的调查，探究“吸我的下体”这些话对那个孩子、对老师、对班级的意义和影响。
But that's kind of the idea, that kids are a long-term project, and over time, angry, hard kids become people who can explain themselves. At Lyons, they call this transformation "being Lyonized." The assistant principal was telling me about this, about how kids get Lyonized.
但这就是一种想法，即孩子是一个长期的项目，随着时间的推移，愤怒、难对付的孩子会成为能够解释自己的人。在里昂，他们称这种转变叫做“里昂化”。副校长正向我讲述这一点，关于孩子们如何被“里昂化”。
And a ninth grader named Nelson happened to be just sitting with us. So she said, "Like Nelson. In sixth grade--"
而一个叫尼尔森（Nelson）的九年级学生碰巧就和我们坐在一起。所以她说：“就像尼尔森。在六年级时——”
He was constantly talking, constantly throwing things, constantly getting kicked out of class, constantly.
他总是说话，总是扔东西，总是被踢出教室，总是这样。
Nelson is not squirming or grimacing listening to this. The feeling is more of a loving parent teasing a grown child about what an awful teenager he was. But of course, what's so remarkable is Nelson is still a teenager. And this is not his parent. It's his principal.
尼尔森听着这些话时并没有坐立不安或皱眉。那种感觉更像是一个慈爱的父母在拿一个长大的孩子开玩笑，说他以前是个多么糟糕的青少年。但当然，最显著的是尼尔森仍然是个青少年。而这并不是他的家长。这是他的校长。
You didn't make it through a class, rarely, even when I had you in small group in sixth grade. It was rough.
你甚至很少能坚持上完一堂课，即使我在六年级把你带进小组时也是如此。那是段艰难的时光。
Is that true?
那是真的吗？
Some of it.
部分是真的。
You remember. It's not like you don't remember.
你记得的。并不是说你不记得了。
Not in that small group. The small group, I wasn't bad.
那个小组不是。那个小组，我没表现坏。
That's not true. That's not true. You have selective memory. It's not true.
那不是真的。那不是真的。你有选择性记忆。那不是真的。
Nelson tells me, "Just ask Espy what I was like in sixth grade." Espy is Dan Espinoza, a dean at the school.
尼尔森告诉我：“去问问艾斯皮（Espy）我六年级时是什么样。”艾斯皮是丹·埃斯皮诺萨（Dan Espinoza），学校的一位训导主任。
Oh, god. As a sixth grader, he was a very, very angry kid. And even through most of his middle school, he'd be a kid that would just wander the halls for hours on end. No one could talk to him. No one could stop him-- don't touch me, get off me. He would be like, "These f-in' deans. He would always say that.
天哪。作为六年级学生，他是一个非常非常愤怒的孩子。甚至在整个初中阶段的大部分时间里，他都是那种会在走廊里游荡好几个小时的孩子。没人能跟他说话。没人能阻止他——别碰我，离我远点。他会说：“这些该死的训导主任。”他总是那么说。
One day, a girl said something nasty to Nelson, and he started screaming at her and then chasing her out of the classroom.
有一天，一个女孩对尼尔森说了些难听的话，他开始对她大喊大叫，然后追着她跑出了教室。
Espy stood by the door so Nelson couldn't run after her. And he looked at me, and he was like, "Dan, I swear to god, I'm about to punch you in the groin right now"-- he said that to me-- "if you don't let go of the door." So I put my foot in the door so that he couldn't open it. And he knew it, and he stopped it at my foot, and then he just pulled harder. And I was--
艾斯皮站在门口，这样尼尔森就没法追她了。他看着我，就像是：“丹，我发誓，如果你不从门上让开，我马上就要往你裆部揍一拳”——他对我说了那话——“如果你不从门上让开。”所以我把脚放在门上，这样他就没法打开它。而他知道，他对着我的脚停下了，然后他只是更用力地拉。而我当时——
What happened?
发生了什么？
It hit me right in the face.
它直接打在我的脸上了。
When I asked him how hard, Espy said, "It didn't break my jaw or anything." So that was sixth grade. Nelson is in ninth grade now, Lyonized.
当我问他有多重时，艾斯皮说：“并没有打断我的下巴什么的。”所以那是六年级。尼尔森现在是九年级了，“里昂化”了。
I mean, I could tell Nelson, "Nelson, I love you." He'll be like, "I love you, too." And it's just a very good--
我的意思是，我可以告诉尼尔森，“尼尔森，我爱你。”他会说，“我也爱你。”那是一种非常好的——
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. It's a very positive relationship at this point. I really don't worry about Nelson. I don't worry. I think he's going to be OK.
是的。目前是一种非常积极的关系。我真的不担心尼尔森。我不担心。我想他会好起来的。
Schools, like any institution, I guess, tend to attract believers, some more fervent than others. But Lyons is a building of believers. This is the way to do things, and it's the right way.
我想，学校像任何机构一样，倾向于吸引信徒，有些比其他人更狂热。但里昂是一个信徒的建筑。这是做事的方法，而且是正确的方法。
Which is why I want to tell you about what happened on May 7 last spring, something that threatened to reverse years of progress with Nelson and had lots of teachers in the school questioning what they're doing here. On May 7, two teachers named Chelsea and Jesse took a group of ninth graders on a field trip. It was an art class. They were going to Manhattan to look at public art. And even on the walk to the train, kids were noticing public artwork.
这就是为什么我想告诉你去年春天5月7日发生的事情，那件事威胁要推翻尼尔森多年来的进步，并让学校里的许多老师质疑他们在这里所做的事情。5月7日，两位老师切尔西（Chelsea）和杰西（Jesse）带着一群九年级学生去实地考察。那是一节美术课。他们要去曼哈顿看公共艺术。即使在去火车站的路上，孩子们也在注意公共艺术品。
It was a beautiful day. We got on the train. Everything was pleasant and calm. Chelsea's at one door. I'm at the other. Kids are standing in the aisle. Most of the seats were taken when we got on.
那是美好的一天。我们上了火车。一切都愉快而平静。切尔西在门口。我在另一个门口。孩子们站在过道里。我们上车时大多数座位都坐满了。
I remember standing with a group of kids around me. And we were all just kind of chatting, who they're dating or just talking about life. Everything seemed so calm. I think we're on the train for two stops, and the train doors open. And someone comes from behind Nelson. So Nelson is standing at the middle pole of the train. And someone pushes past him, kind of shoulders him out of the way, and steps off the train.
我记得我和一群孩子围在一起。我们只是在聊天，谈论他们和谁约会，或者只是谈论生活。一切看起来那么平静。我想我们在火车上坐了两站，车门开了。有人从尼尔森身后走来。所以尼尔森站在火车的中间杆旁。有人推开他，肩膀撞了他一下，走下了火车。
And Nelson responds by saying, "Say excuse me." And the man now, who's outside of the train, turns around and starts cursing at Nelson. I don't remember exactly what he said, something like, who the fuck are you, or, shut the fuck up, or something very aggressive, very unnecessary.
而尼尔森的回应是说：“说声对不起。”那个现在已经下车的人转过身，开始对着尼尔森咒骂。我不记得他确切说了什么，类似于“你算个屁”或者“闭上你的臭嘴”，或者一些非常有攻击性、非常没必要的话。
Nelson didn't say it in a nice way. He was just like, "Say excuse me." Definitely not within his place to be speaking to an older man that way, but still, not horrible. Chelsea says the man was big, big enough that she wouldn't have messed with him and big enough that, Nelson says, when he bumped into him, it was a real shove.
尼尔森说得并不客气。他只是说：“说声对不起。”对他那个年纪来说，那样对待一个年长的男人确实不太合适，但也不算糟糕。切尔西说那个男人很大块头，大到她不会去招惹他，而且大到尼尔森说，当他撞到他时，那真的是一种推搡。
It's rude people on the train. They'll just bump into you without saying excuse me or sorry. I told him, "Say excuse me. You could have said excuse me."
火车上的人很粗鲁。他们会撞到你而不说对不起。我告诉他：“说声对不起。你本可以说对不起的。”
And then he said something right back?
然后他说了什么回敬你？
Said, "Fuck you." I said, "Fuck you, too."
他说，“去你妈的。”我说，“去你妈的。”
There are a lot of versions of what happened next. Some students say the guy reached to grab Nelson, to hit him. Some of them say the guy just stepped forward. Teachers and students, everyone, says, at that point, the kids, a large group of them, moved in on the man.
接下来发生的事情有很多版本。一些学生说那个男人伸手要抓尼尔森、要打他。其中一些人说那个男人只是向前跨了一步。老师和学生，每个人都说，就在那时，孩子们，一大群人，围住了那个男人。
It was kind of like slow motion. And I could see a volcano erupting. And I just immediately put my arms across the door, because he was outside, and they were inside. And I wanted to keep them inside, and I wanted to keep him outside.
就像是慢动作。我可以看到一座火山爆发。我立刻把双臂挡在门口，因为他在外面，他们在里面。我想让他们留在里面，我想让他留在外面。
The doors were going to close soon. They're just yelling. They can yell, and then we'll move on.
门很快就会关上。他们只是在大喊。他们可以大喊，然后我们就继续走。
And Chelsea put her arms across the doors to keep the kids behind her inside the train. But for some reason, the doors did not close. The train did not move.
切尔西把双臂横在门上，把她身后的孩子们挡在车厢里。但出于某种原因，门没有关。火车没有动。
It definitely escalated very quickly. They were trying to hit him over me. They threw a bottle. Somebody spit. I mean, it was really gross.
事态确实升级得非常快。他们试图越过我打他。他们扔了一个瓶子。有人吐了口水。我的意思是，那真的很恶心。
Jesse, meanwhile, the other teacher, was at the other end of the train car. So he couldn't see what was going on. But he stepped out onto the platform, and he sees this man there, screaming.
杰西，与此同时，另一位老师，在车厢的另一头。所以他看不到发生了什么。但他走上了站台，看到那个男人在那儿，尖叫着。
And Chelsea is between him and the students. It appeared that he was reaching over, trying to grab a student. And he's saying something like, I want this fucking kid, or, give me this fucking kid, something like that.
切尔西就在他和学生之间。看起来他正伸手试图抓住一个学生。他说着类似“我要这个该死的小孩”或者“给我这个该死的小孩”之类的话。
So I was really concerned that he was mentally unstable. And so I ran. I actually sort of-- so I slipped myself between him and Chelsea.
所以我非常担心他精神不稳定。所以我跑了。实际上——我把自己插在了他和切尔西之间。
I was facing him. And so I actually saw him reach into his pocket. And I got really-- I was like, oh, my god. Does this guy have some sort of weapon?
我正面对着他。我确实看到他伸手进兜。我当时真的——我心想，天哪。这个家伙有什么武器吗？
I actually put my hands on his chest to push him away. And right when I did that, we locked eyes, and he said, "I'm a cop. I'm a cop. I'm a cop."
我确实把手放在他的胸口把他推开。就在我那样做的时候，我们锁定了眼神，他说：“我是警察。我是警察。我是警察。”
When I asked the kids about this moment later, a bunch of them told me the whole thing was so confusing until right then. The whole time, they were wondering, what's this random guy doing starting with us? And then, when they found out he's a cop, it was like, oh, that's why he's acting like that.
当我后来问孩子们关于那一刻时，他们中的一群人告诉我整件事太令人困惑了，直到那一刻。一直以来，他们都在想，这个随便的家伙到底是干嘛的，怎么跟我们找茬？然后，当他们发现他是警察时，感觉就像是：哦，这就是他为什么那样表现。
But Jesse and Chelsea both said this is where they got confused. The man made more sense to them as a crazy guy than as an officer, a plainclothes officer, who was now standing on a subway platform with his badge saying he got hit, and he wanted everyone off the train.
但杰西和切尔西都说这是他们感到困惑的地方。那个男人与其说是警官，不如说是疯子，现在他正站在地铁站台上，带着徽章说他被打，并要求所有人下车。
Yeah, he's like, give me this kid, I want that one, give me the tall one, the short one, who were huddled on the platform. He's picking-- he had one student and was asking for more.
是的，他就像是：给我这个孩子，我要那个，把那个高的给我，矮的那个，他们蜷缩在站台上。他在挑人——他抓了一个学生，并要求更多人。
He was very, very, very angry. You know when someone's so angry that spit is coming out of their mouth? Yeah. When he was talking to us and talking to the kids, he was filled with fury.
他非常非常愤怒。你知道当一个人那么愤怒以至于口水从嘴里喷出来的时候吗？是的。当他跟我们和孩子们交谈时，他充满了狂怒。
Jesse says the cop pulled aside Nelson, Alex-- that kid who told me Lyons made him capable of talking to me-- and a boy named Kamani. Jesse tried to stay close to the group.
杰西说警察把尼尔森、亚历克斯——那个告诉我说里昂让他能跟我说话的孩子——还有一个叫卡马尼（Kamani）的男孩拉到一边。杰西试图靠近那群人。
I'm saying, "Wait, why do you want them?" And at some point in there, I made it clear. I said, "I'm their teacher. They're with me on a class trip. We need to talk about this."
我说：“等等，你为什么想要他们？”在那过程中的某个点，我表达清楚了。我说：“我是他们的老师。他们是和我一起参加班级旅行的。我们需要讨论这件事。”
And he's saying, "I'm going to get six more officers here in a second." And he really did. He called, and there were a bunch more plainclothes officers there really quickly.
而他说：“我马上会叫六名警官过来。”他真的叫了，很快就有更多便衣警官到了那里。
Jesse pressed on. And the more he recounted this to me, I realized, oh, he's trying to do restorative justice with the guy. He was in teacher mode. He's got 25 of his students standing before him. So without thinking, he does what he knows how to do.
杰西坚持下去。随着他向我叙述得越多，我意识到，哦，他正在试图对那个家伙使用恢复性司法。他正处于老师模式。他面前站着25个学生。所以他想都没想，就做了他知道该怎么做的事。
You know, let's talk about this. There must be a way we can work this out. You don't have to arrest them. I have a whole class here.
你知道，我们谈谈这件事吧。一定有一种方法可以解决这个问题。你不必逮捕他们。我带了整个班级在这里。
And you thought, I just need to explain to him what's going on.
你当时心想，我只需要向他解释发生了什么。
Yeah, if I could explain to him, we're on a class trip, and whatever happened must have been some big misunderstanding. Maybe he didn't know you were a cop. Maybe you shouldn't have cursed at him right away. Maybe he shouldn't have said, "Say excuse me," with that particular tone. And if I can help you two see that right now, then everything can be OK. And he wasn't trying to hear any of that.
是的，如果我能向他解释我们正在进行班级旅行，无论发生了什么肯定是一个巨大的误会。也许他不知道你是警察。也许你不该直接对他咒骂。也许他不该用那种特别的语气说“说声对不起”。如果我能帮助你们两人现在就明白这一点，那一切都可以解决。但他根本不想听任何那些。
What was he saying?
他在说什么？
He actually then threatened me and said that, if I don't get away, that he was going to arrest me.
他实际上威胁我，说如果我不走开，他就会逮捕我。
Restorative justice, meet plain old criminal justice. The cop was not about to sit in a circle. He was going to make some arrests.
恢复性司法，遇见了老式的刑事司法。警察根本不打算坐下来围成一圈。他要进行逮捕。
And the kids geared into action. They shot video, started calling mothers and aunts and girlfriends. Someone made sure to get their backpacks.
孩子们行动起来了。他们拍摄视频，开始呼叫妈妈、阿姨和女朋友。有人确保拿上了他们的书包。
Nelson's classmate Brianna got Nelson's phone out of his pocket while he was handcuffed. I asked Brianna how she knew to do that when someone was arrested. She was quiet for a couple seconds, like she was trying to figure out what exactly I meant by that question. And then her face cleared up, and she said, oh, I live here. I live in Brooklyn.
尼尔森的同学布里安娜（Brianna）在尼尔森戴上手铐时把他口袋里的电话拿了出来。我问布里安娜当有人被捕时她是怎么知道该那么做的。她沉默了几秒钟，好像她在试图弄清楚我问那个问题到底是什么意思。然后她的脸变得清晰，她说，哦，我住在这里。我住在布鲁克林。
I immediately got the sense that seeing their friends in handcuffs was nothing new to them at all. And that's a really scary thought. And it's something that I know, but to see it in that moment where it's so clear no one is shocked.
我立刻感觉到，看着他们的朋友戴上手铐对他们来说一点也不新鲜。这是一个非常可怕的想法。这是我知道的事情，但在那个时刻看到它，显然没人感到震惊。
About what's happening right there.
关于正在发生的事。
Yeah. People are angry, but no one is surprised. And seeing how normal it is for some kids is, yeah, that's scary.
是的。人们很生气，但没人感到惊讶。看到这对一些孩子来说是多么常态化，是的，那很可怕。
The cop arrested Nelson and Kamani. The rest of the kids watched. Nelson was charged with disorderly conduct. Kamani was charged with a felony for assaulting an officer.
警察逮捕了尼尔森和卡马尼。剩下的孩子看着。尼尔森被控行为不检。卡马尼被控袭击警察的重罪。
The NYPD declined multiple requests for an interview or any kind of response. And the officer-- his name is Guillermo Lozano-- would not talk to me. He also didn't show up for Nelson's court dates. He did provide the courts with a written statement that says, after a heated verbal exchange with Nelson, the officer identified himself. Kamani, the statement says, then punched him in the right eye and yelled, "Fuck that."
纽约警察局拒绝了多次采访或任何形式回应的请求。而那位警官——他叫吉列尔莫·洛萨诺（Guillermo Lozano）——不愿与我交谈。他也没出席尼尔森的法庭审理日期。他确实向法庭提供了一份书面陈述，称在与尼尔森发生激烈的口头交锋后，该警官表明了身份。卡马尼，陈述称，随后打了他的右眼并喊道：“去他的。”
Kamani denies this. But in court, he took a plea deal. All of the witnesses I spoke with say the cop did not identify himself until after the scuffle. Two people said, at that point, he did appear to have a mark on his face. Nelson and Kamani were booked and spent the night in jail. They were both 16.
卡马尼否认了这一点。但在法庭上，他接受了认罪协议。我交谈过的所有证人都说，直到混战结束后警察才表明身份。两个人说，在那一点上，他的脸上确实出现了一个印记。尼尔森和卡马尼被登记并被关押了一夜。他们都16岁。
Everybody's in there for different stuff. So at that point, you just feel like you've just got to watch over yourself, because there's dangerous people in there. You've just got to be cool.
每个人都在那里因为不同的事。所以在那一点上，你只是觉得你得看着点自己，因为里面有危险的人。你必须保持冷静。
Was this other kids or grownups?
那是其他孩子还是成年人？
Grownups. To me, they was a little crazy, because they're just doing random shit and crazy stuff.
成年人。对我来说，他们有点疯，因为他们只是在做乱七八糟的事和疯狂的事。
Like what?
比如什么？
Crazy stuff, like grown people getting caught with guns and stuff. It's just weird, because you're just looking at them like, damn. I didn't sleep.
疯狂的事，比如成年人因为枪支之类的事被抓。这很奇怪，因为你只是看着他们心想，该死。我没睡。
Yeah, it seems like it'd be hard to sleep.
是的，看起来那很难入睡。
I was up the whole night.
我整晚都没睡。
Did you just sit up the whole night?
你只是整晚坐着吗？
I had my hoodie over my head, just thinking.
我把卫衣帽子戴在头上，只是思考。
Were you scared?
你害怕吗？
Not really. I kind of was, but I wasn't.
并不是真的很害怕。我有点害怕，但又没害怕。
I asked Nelson what he was thinking about all night.
我问尼尔森整晚在想什么。
If he was a cop, why'd he tell me fuck you? Because he could have said something else if he's that smart enough to be a cop.
如果他是个警察，为什么他要对我说“去你妈的”？因为如果他聪明到能当警察，他本可以说点别的。
Like what?
比如什么？
I don't know. Like, sorry, my fault. It just made no sense. He's a grown-ass man, and I'm a little kid. He should have just kept going.
我不知道。比如，对不起，是我的错。这根本没有意义。他是个成年男人，而我只是个小孩子。他本该直接走开的。
When Nelson got out the next morning, he came straight to school. He said he wanted to let his teachers know he was OK.
当尼尔森第二天早上出来时，他直接去了学校。他说他想让他的老师知道他没事。
The principal of Lyons, Taeko Onishi, sends out a weekly email to staff. And that week, it described the arrests and said, "There's an impending court case, so I won't get into too much detail. But it was one of those cases of a cop undercover, responding completely inappropriately to our students, our students then responding inappropriately back. Clearly, the cop was in the wrong. But equally clearly, many of our students really struggle to make the best of choices when faced with an emotionally charged situation."
里昂的校长泰科·奥尼什（Taeko Onishi）给教职员工发了一封每周电子邮件，那一周，它描述了逮捕事件，并说：“有一场即将到来的法庭案件，所以我不会详细说明。但这是警察在便衣行动中对应我们的学生完全不恰当，我们的学生又以不恰当的方式回应的案例之一。显然，警察是错的。但同样清楚的是，当面临情绪激动的局面时，我们的许多学生确实在努力做出最好的选择。”
Of course, Lyons staff discussed the incident exhaustively.
当然，里昂的教职员工进行了详尽的讨论。
I was sick. It's like your worst nightmare. Assaulting an officer sounds so bad.
我当时病了。这就像你的噩梦。袭击警察听起来太糟糕了。
Espy, the dean who tells Nelson he loves him, could not stop imagining Nelson in jail. He imagined Nelson getting his prints taken, standing before a judge, seeing himself as a criminal. And Espy played out the alternate future he could now see for Nelson. Basically, he had the same moment Tunette had with JJ, seeing a path laid out before him, seeing him targeted by strangers who don't see him for who he is. It made Espy furious.
艾斯皮，那位告诉尼尔森他爱他的训导主任，无法停止想象尼尔森在监狱里。他想象着尼尔森被按手印，站在法官面前，把自己看作罪犯。而艾斯皮演练了尼尔森现在可以预见到的另一种未来。基本上，他有了和图内特关于JJ一样的时刻，看着一条铺在他面前的道路，看到他被不认识他的人瞄准。这让艾斯皮非常愤怒。
But other teachers at Lyons took the news of the arrests differently. Kamani's English teacher, Cindy Black, said she kept thinking about all the times Kamani acted out in her class, blew up, threw books on the floor. And she kept wondering, is what we're doing working for the kids?
但里昂的其他老师对被捕的消息采取了不同的看法。卡马尼的英语老师辛迪·布莱克（Cindy Black）说，她一直想到卡马尼在她的课上表现出的所有时候，爆炸，把书扔在地上。她一直问自己，我们对孩子们做的事奏效吗？
And so when I first heard about what had happened, my immediate reaction was, oh, no. It's our fault. We've allowed him to get away with too much. We should have been suspending him more.
所以当我第一次听到发生什么事时，我的第一反应是，哦，不。是我们的错。我们允许他逃脱的事情太多了。我们本应该更多地让他停课。
We should have been more black and white. We shouldn't have turned away when he did these outrageous things. We should have held him more accountable.
我们本应该更黑白分明。我们本不该在他做那些令人震惊的事情时转过身去。我们本应该让他承担更多责任。
And we didn't do any of that stuff. And so it's our fault he's done something now. He spent the night in jail. It's because of us. It's because of me.
而我们没有做任何那些事。所以这是我们的错，他现在做了某些事。他在监狱里过了一夜。那是因为我们。那是因为我。
Here's Chelsea.
这是切尔西。
Because maybe if we were a different kind of school, they would not have acted that way on a trip. I don't know if kids would have felt the freedom to act that way.
因为也许如果我们是不同类型的学校，他们就不会在旅行中表现得那样。我不知道孩子们是否会感到表现那样的自由。
Freedom to say "excuse me" to a stranger in a rude tone, to throw stuff, and to talk back. It seemed like the cop saw them as rowdy or threatening. What if they'd been more like Rousseau's students, quiet and in uniforms, doing homework? Maybe this whole thing could've been avoided.
以粗鲁的语气对陌生人说“对不起”的自由，扔东西的自由，回嘴的自由。看起来警察把他们视为吵闹或有威胁性的。如果他们更像卢梭的学生，穿着制服、安静地做作业呢？也许整件事本来是可以避免的。
But Espy reminded everyone, wait, the cop said, "Fuck you." Kamani only got involved when the cop started with Nelson. We're going to tell them he should have held back?
但艾斯皮提醒大家，等等，警察说了“去你妈的”。卡马尼只有在警察开始找尼尔森茬时才卷入。我们要告诉他们他本该退缩吗？
Are you kidding me? When his friend is getting pulled by a plainclothed guy? How do you-- I just don't-- because I know, if I was there, I would be arrested, because if someone's grabbing Nelson and it's just a guy, I'm going to-- so I would have been arrested.
你在开玩笑吗？当他的朋友被一个便衣家伙拉扯时？你怎么——我只是不——因为我知道，如果我在那儿，我会被捕，因为如果有人抓尼尔森而且那只是个家伙，我会——所以我会被捕。
And this guy clearly had a-- everybody around said Nelson said, "You could say excuse me." That's the first thing Nelson said, when the first thing the guy says is, "Fuck you." And this is a kid who we're trying to teach, be patient, don't confront somebody. And I thought he did a pretty good job. But once you say, "Fuck you," to Nelson, the restorative justice doesn't work beyond that point.
而这个家伙显然有一个——周围每个人都说尼尔森说，“你本可以说对不起的。”那是尼尔森说的第一句话，而那个家伙说的第一句话是“去你妈的”。这是一个我们试图教导的孩子，要耐心，不要对抗某人。我觉得他做得相当好。但一旦你对尼尔森说“去你妈的”，恢复性司法在那一点之后就不起作用了。
Still, restorative justice is what the school does. So after Jesse and Chelsea got the rest of the class back to school, they set them down in a circle. Here's Alex.
尽管如此，恢复性司法是学校所做的事。所以杰西和切尔西把班上剩下的孩子带回学校后，他们让他们坐成一圈。这是亚历克斯。
Just talking about what happened at that day and what we could have did to stop it.
只是讨论那天发生了什么以及我们能做什么来阻止它。
What could you guys have done to stop it?
你们能做什么来阻止它？
I don't know. We can't stop something like that. The police officer just took them for no reason. We can't stop-- we can't change his mind as Jesse tried to change his mind. He didn't want to change his mind.
我不知道。我们阻止不了那种事。警察只是无缘无故地带走了他们。我们阻止不了——我们改变不了他的想法，就像杰西试图改变他的想法一样。他不想改变他的想法。
So your circle was about what you could do to stop it, but you felt like there was nothing that you could do to stop it?
所以你们的圆圈是为了讨论你们能做什么来阻止它，但你觉得你们什么也做不了？
Yeah. I didn't really feel like telling nobody. So I didn't really feel like talking about it.
是的。我真的不想告诉任何人。所以我真的不想谈论它。
In other words, nothing that we could do, nothing you teachers can do, would have stopped that. I heard this from a lot of kids, the feeling that your funky little system is cool when we're in school and all, but don't try and take it and apply it to our world. You're in over your head.
换句话说，我们什么也做不了，你们这些老师什么也做不了，都阻止不了那一幕。我从很多孩子那里听到了这一点，那种感觉你们那套奇特的系统在学校里挺酷，但别试图把它应用到我们的世界。你们在做超出你们能力的事。
If talking in circles are not the way the world does things, then Lyons is failing to prepare kids for the world they live in. And if they're not preparing kids for the world they live in, they're not doing their job, right? Isn't that their job? Is that their job?
如果围成圆圈谈话不是世界做事的方式，那么里昂就没有准备好让孩子们面对他们所生活的世界。如果他们没有准备好让孩子们面对他们所生活的世界，他们就没有在做他们的工作，对吧？那不是他们的工作吗？那是他们的工作吗？
This is the question I keep coming back to, thinking about all these stories. It's the same question Rousseau, at his no-excuses charter school, is asking.
这是我一直思考所有这些故事时回到的问题。这是卢梭在没有借口的特许学校里所问的同样的问题。
What is the point of punishment in school? Is it to teach self-control? To get kids to be quiet so learning can happen? To prepare children to function as grownups in the world? To teach them how to avoid being arrested? If you want to know, is this working for the kids, you have to know what you're going for, right?
学校管教的重点是什么？是为了教授自控力？为了让孩子安静以便学习可以发生？为了准备孩子作为成年人在世界上运作？为了教他们如何避免被捕？如果你想知道这是否对孩子们奏效，你必须知道你的目标是什么，对吧？
Every year, teachers have 30 or 100 students. A lot of those kids will be disciplined. And getting it wrong, even once, can be haunting. For example, remember Christopher, the kid who ran around the classroom with his teacher's stapler and Post-It notes coming out of his pockets everywhere? I tried to track Christopher down. I thought it might be interesting to hear what he remembered of the stapler, if he remembered his teacher.
每年，老师们有30或100名学生。其中很多孩子会被管教。而做错了，哪怕一次，都会让人难以忘怀。例如，记得克里斯托弗吗，那个带着老师订书机和便利贴四处乱跑的孩子？我试着追踪克里斯托弗。我觉得听听他对订书机的记忆，如果他记得他的老师，可能会很有趣。
And I found him, just last month in a Manhattan courthouse. He was being sentenced to six months at Rikers Island for burglary. Christopher's seventh-grade teacher did not cause that. But when I told Ms. Furr, she got really quiet, ended our call kind of abruptly, and then wrote me this.
而我发现他了，就在上个月曼哈顿的一所法院里。他因为入室行窃被判在赖克斯岛（Rikers Island）待六个月。克里斯托弗的七年级老师没有导致那个结果。但当我告诉弗尔老师时，她变得非常安静，有点唐突地结束了通话，然后写给我这个。
"I was so heartbroken to hear the news about Christopher's recent trouble. All the times I talked about behavior with him, I wish I would have talked about how quick that he was at math and how much I liked to hear him read out loud. If you do speak to him, please tell him I'm glad to help in any way possible."
“听到关于克里斯托弗最近的麻烦的消息，我非常心碎。所有我谈论他行为的时光，我真希望我当时谈论的是他数学有多快，以及我有多喜欢听他大声朗读。如果你确实跟他说话，请告诉他我很乐意以任何方式提供帮助。”
Katie Furr has no idea if those things would have made any difference, and I don't either. And I wasn't able to reach the one person who might have something to say about that, because he has been removed from the community, something he's gone through many times before, starting at least as early as seventh grade.
凯蒂·弗尔不知道那些事是否有任何不同，我也不知道。而我没能联系上那个可能对那件事有话要说的人，因为他已经被从社区移除，这是他多次经历的事情，至少从七年级就开始了。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program today was produced by Nancy Updike with help from Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Editing help today from Paul Tough, production help from JP Dukes.
我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作，本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）提供协助。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。今天编辑协助来自保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough），制作协助来自JP·杜克斯（JP Dukes）。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef. Special thanks to Ta-Nehisi Coates, Joel Lovell, Rebecca Decola, Robert Murphey, Nava EtShalom, Judge Elijah Williams, Jamaal Bowman, Liz Fletcher, Judith Kafka, Ronald Butchart, Kelly King, Kathy Brody, Lamar Shambley, Kathy Cohen, James Settle, Tom Ryder, Matt Lunt, Janet Bass at the American Federation of Teachers, Amanda Pinto at the Achievement First Network, and the entire staff of Lyons Community School.
塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。今天研究协助来自克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）。特别感谢塔-内西·科茨（Ta-Nehisi Coates）、乔尔·洛维尔（Joel Lovell）、丽贝卡·德科拉（Rebecca Decola）、罗伯特·墨菲（Robert Murphey）、纳瓦·埃特沙洛姆（Nava EtShalom）、埃利亚·威廉姆斯（Elijah Williams）法官、贾马尔·鲍曼（Jamaal Bowman）、利兹·弗莱彻（Liz Fletcher）、朱迪思·卡夫卡（Judith Kafka）、罗纳德·布切特（Ronald Butchart）、凯莉·金（Kelly King）、凯西·布罗迪（Kathy Brody）、拉马尔·沙姆布利（Lamar Shambley）、凯西·科恩（Kathy Cohen）、詹姆斯·塞特尔（James Settle）、汤姆·莱德（Tom Ryder）、马特·伦特（Matt Lunt）、美国教师联合会的珍妮特·巴斯（Janet Bass）、成就第一网络的阿曼达·平托（Amanda Pinto）以及里昂社区学校的全体员工。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, every day he spent as general manager of WBEZ included that very special and memorable moment when he would stand in the hallway and yell--
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换系统分发给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他在WBEZ担任总经理期间度过的每一天都包括那个非常特别和令人难忘的时刻，当他站在走廊里大喊——
I run this mother.
我统治这里。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。